[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and I'll show you how
App Engine can help you ship your next
great app idea App Engine is a fully
managed server list application platform
with simple administration write your
code and any of the supported languages
or run custom containers with the
language and framework of your choice
when your code is ready run g-cloud app
deploy App Engine handles the work of
uploading your code and running it on
Google Cloud it seamlessly scales from
zero to millions of requests as your app
becomes popular and you only pay for
what you use you can easily host
different versions of your app and split
traffic between them for a/b testing and
incremental future rollouts you can
debug and monitor your app even in
production and for the security of your
app App Engine offers free managed ssl
certificates on your custom domain App
Engine works as a great back-end for
mobile apps api's websites and more so
next time you've got a cool app you want
to ship quickly take a minute to look at
App Engine to learn more check out cloud
google.com slash App Engine